[Music]
B are you ready for them
yeah yeah what else is there other than
to be
ready how
you
[Music]
foreen look it look get
[Applause]
[Music]
it
[Applause]
[Music]
you
welcome to
Cy
[Music]
Freedom comes to those who fight but
know to those who cry cuz the more you
cry it's the more your people continue
to die so rise defend
[Music]
your ucation is too
high you see the tribalism is too much I
would like to communicate for the things
that we have be eliminate ignorance and
[Music]
eradicate
left to left to Super left
left
the time I met him was at University
when I was still The Village
girl
yeah he was in his second year at
University was studying drama and music
and dance and we met at the National
Theater I was cast in a play It's called
lady will you marry me we didn't know
each other we didn't even like each
other cuz I came from a crazy world and
to me she came from a weird world yes
she had a mom and dad and um a good
family she was very beautiful moralistic
too
moralistic he came from the ghetto he
had no father he had no M he lived
alone he was
different I was a ra muffin rough hair
bruised Knuckles every time she looked
at me she's like
do you have
parents and I'm like do you have a
life I was always asking myself how do
people like live like this how do you
live in
Islam that smells the way it
does you're not sure what you're going
to eat tomorrow you don't have a mother
you don't have a dad if I ask you where
your brother ah he went to town to work
who paid your school fees I paid my own
school
fees I didn't no no he was a musician
one day he says last night I had a very
big show in baras that side of yours and
I'm like a show said oh I never told you
I'm a musician I said musician said yes
I'm Bobby said huh you
Bobby you can't be Robert and Bobby wine
at the same time said I
am I didn't have so many
dreams I just wanted to have my good
small car and good small house in the
ghetto and that's it
but when I met her and the things that
she was saying and things that we talked
with her made me realize that I can
actually impact
lives we can impact life she impacted my
life I had to impact other
lives she redefined me I must
say I started feeling loved I started
feeling appreciated by the same time I
started feeling
vulnerable if he decides to do something
something thing nothing will stop him
and he does not need validation from
anyone I can't tell what Bobby would be
tomorrow I cannot it's very
unpredictable I don't know that's all I
can say I don't
know this year's presidential election
could see 71-year-old President Yi Moi
serve a fifth term in
[Applause]
office the campaigns have been marred by
protest violence and the repeated
Detention of the main opposition Vader
Dr Kiza
BJ what policing equipment is
there this must
stop if Mr does not want election he
doesn't have to call any but if you call
an election Let It Be an election
dictators all over the world rule until
they are pushed out or they die they
don't have to disturb
people pres promising Uganda things to
happen it's now 30 years and there's no
change he has made government has lost
the grip for which the ugandans
supported 198
UGA
[Music]
bye bye
bye Bobby wine has announced he will run
for the Parliamentary seat in chondo
East which fell vacant earlier this
year you know I always thought somebody
had to speak for
us and uh people thought I had the
loudest voice around not because I know
everything not because I'm the most
intelligent but maybe because of the
music that kind of projected our
plight so when they asked me to stand
represent them I
[Music]
agree Bob came to Parliament today to be
sworn in as the new MP for chondo County
East he won a recent byelection with
over 34 of the people's
vote
[Music]
I Robert swear in the name of the
almighty God that I will be faithful and
bear true allegiance to the Republic of
Uganda and that I will Preserve protect
and defend the Constitution so
[Music]
help I've come to Parliament at a very
sensitive
time a time when there's an impending
Bill to lift the age limit for the
presidency um I've just taken an oath to
defend reserve and protect the
constitution of the Republic of Uganda
and that is going to be my major major
goal right
[Applause]
now president KAG uh welcome to this
show and thank you for talking to Al
thank you Mr President it seems that
ugandans are a little bit fed up with
you because it's more than three decades
of your leadership and the world around
Uganda has changed all presidents around
Uganda have gone but you so do do you
agree with me that there is a little bit
of you know fatigue we had
elections about one year ago and I got
my party got uh
62% of the vote so that does not show
that uh the people of Uganda are fed up
of our party because they have voted for
us five times
after five
terms you are now 71 or 72 I don't know
72 in 3 years you will be you will reach
the age limit and you can't run for
another term mhm are you going to run
for another term we follow our
constitution we follow so you're not
going to run for another ter we follow
our constitution because you reach the
age limit in 3 years and you will not
run we follow the constition of Uganda
is this something that is in the
discussion now in Uganda that is
speculation and I don't have time for
speculation here in Uganda members of
parliament from the nrm will be seeking
for leave of parliament to draft a
private members Bill to scrap article
102 of the Constitution which means that
President TR is able to stand come
2021 the heavy police deployment did not
deter two youths who chained themselves
to concrete blocks just outside
parliament's main
gate for us we just doing our
job okay let us do our job let
us going we have to defend our we have
to defend
[Music]
our several opposition politicians
opposed to the age limit Bill were
arrested including the mayor of
calam I was TR shocked to find these
people sing off my home they had not
explained anything to me they had put
barricades along the way they brought
several Patrol Vehicles as you see them
here as my kids were being taken school
they were subjected to
hor officers I've committed an office
please please
[Music]
please
trans what is the purpose of theit when
the government disrespect the
Constitution where is
my
what to
[Music]
this un you whether you a soldier you a
lawyer or you a policeman do we have to
put lawyer no teacher but lawyers are
important
also again one more confident time me
this whether you a doctor or a farmer
could I be a teacher or policeman could
I be a tax driver or a student could I
be a lawyer could I be a soldier we
are we are figh
[Music]
for at around 12:00 Robert Jag set up
from his home for consultations fled by
his
supporters
at every stop he asked the governed
residents their position regarding the
lifting of the presidential age
[Applause]
limit
Pres
[Music]
drama continues to follow a proposed
Bill to lift the presidential age limit
for
Uganda two opposition lawmakers were
pushed into security trucks while trying
to enter
Parliament it does not scare
me does not scare me because I know
those people are not any difference from
us they face the same challenges they
have the same struggle of Life they also
want
freedom and I know that one day they are
going to join
us and know that for sure it's just a
matter of
timeable speaker and colleague
members it has been said that there
Comes A Time in the life of every nation
when it comes to a crossroad and must
choose which way to
go my friends if there is a time that
Uganda has come to that point it is
today and if there's a parliament upon
which
history has best told a very big
responsibility it is
ours honorable speaker and members I
have the rare opportunity to Traverse
the whole country and everywhere been
from north to south from the East to the
West people are saying they not touch
our
constitution these people are connected
to the world and they've been seeing
what happens in countries around us
where leaders thought that they can rule
their countes for life and that is why
they want to avoid it before it comes
here
today MERS we have a chance to solve the
problems of our grandfathers and
grandmothers we have the chance to do
that we have the chance to reverse that
and it is important that we serve our
children and the children of our
children from this madness thank you
very much mad
speaker
where is your where
your members let us proceed with the
[Music]
voting
right honorable speaker it's a strong
yes
H Madame speaker
yes I vote Yes I vote
Yes in respect of the views of my people
I say
[Applause]
no OFA West people I vote a very big
not resounding yes yes
yes on behalf of the people the East and
on behalf of all the GTO people I vote
[Applause]
no they sent me to vote Yes I vote Yes
I
[Applause]
[Music]
here uh onor members this is the
outcome results of the Roll
Call uh abstentions were
two against were 62
in fav
[Applause]
[Music]
315 now declare that the title has
settled and the bill
passes I wish Merry
[Applause]
Christmas I I want to say we have been a
diservice the ten Parliament we have
been disservice to the people of Uganda
and they will forever never forget us
it's unfortunate that there are some
people who think that their future is in
hands of
individuals Uganda will forever remain
our
motherland we do bad to defile her we do
evil to defile the people of this great
pal of Africa thank
you
today was terrible terrible
terrible I always knew that our
politicians are greedy but I do not know
the level of greedy they could go
to I think it's lments that thinking
different
options yeah there's no democracy in
Uganda big you tellig li I you just
fantasize open your eyes better realize
don't see me rise and start crize you
better wake up from your dream better go
up before
you
me
[Music]
[Applause]
me new MP Bobby wine has spent his first
year in office traversing the country in
an attempt to unite the opposition
against President M's
nrm also lending his support to
sympathetic candidates fighting
[Applause]
reelection after victory for the
opposition in ginger East by elction
Bobby Wayne had another success in
bugiri where he backed the winning
candidate asuman basal
today Bobby wine is due to Rally in the
northern town of arua lending his
support to independent candidate casano
[Music]
[Applause]
wad
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you
feel
[Music]
[Applause]
is not a secret
anymore I said is not a secret
anymore that we want to remove
[Applause]
from
people power our power people power our
power our power people power
[Applause]
our one
ofer
C what was the purpose of the Liberation
when we got of peaceful transition what
is the purpose of the Constitution when
the government disrespect the
Constitution where is my freedom of
expression when you tell
me
[Applause]
[Music]
brother
hello Joseph where are
you
yeah okay from continent Pacific this is
Pacific
hello Joseph come to continent they sh
down one of our people they shoot down
our
driver they've killed him now now now
now just come to the
Hotel this must be strong
okay
[Music]
didn't
commit
cage We are following some breaking news
out of Uganda um and I'd like to read a
tweet by Bobby wine himself um just a
couple of minutes ago he said police has
shot my driver dead thinking they've
shot me my hotel is now cordoned off by
police and the
sfc the byelection in aroa has been
disrupted by the arrest of the oppos I
candidate casian wri as well as the
popster MP Bobby wine the police have
accused the arrested politicians of
throwing stones at the presidential
[Music]
motorade in kalala news of Bobby wi's
arrest has provoked strong reactions
throughout the
city this is
our
where is the B you need
bble B to be alive not to die die only
and they must release him our Bob should
be I don't know how I am Monica I am
still trying to make sure that I at
least get access to Bobby when I get to
see him then I can make a proper
conclusion of how I am right now I am on
I'm I'm I'm doing everything on
speculation and that kills
me yeah if I could if I could see him
then I would know what I would I am
actually going to be dealing
with yeah
yeah yeah
thank of course of
course thanks thanks
mon okay okay we'll talk later thank you
I'll give you feedback by the day
all our friends are
concerned everyone is
confused I've been strong but I can't
keep it
anymore this is like the second time
I've cried since all this chaos and it's
all because of everything that is
overwhelming if only I could see him
then I would be stronger I'd be knowing
what exactly I'm do dealing with but I
don't know what I'm dealing with I'm
just imagining
[Music]
everything I've spoking to his lawyer
one of his lawyers who is still in
goo he tells me that Bobby wine is badly
injured he can neither talk properly nor
sit or stand on his own when the charges
were big right to him he did not take
any ple because he could not speak
regarding his condition that's a concern
from his lawyers they want him to to get
medical attention
immediately I really wanted to see him
so I could make my own
analysis and um what I found was worse
than what I thought he has a swollen
head he has red eyes and they're swollen
he he his ears are swollen he has wounds
on the ears his mouth his lips are huge
the whole face is swollen he has pain
and the back the ribs up up to the Heap
he says they squeezed his private parts
he can barely he can
barely
urinate he said L urinated in the
morning and heated past his strong in
his mind he even told one of the people
that we went with who is um part of the
struggle part of their team he told him
even if I die now please make sure you
don't
stop just keep going that will be just
one person out of the league don't
[Music]
stop
my husband is not and has never been in
the
military he has no military experience
does not even know how to use a gun I'm
sure I can't differentiate between
different guns out
there then I wonder why is my husband
killed in a military
B what has he done to deserve
[Music]
[Applause]
this for several days now police have
continued their raids on camela and made
multiple arrests of Bobby wine
supporters
protests in Uganda have led to more than
70 people being arrested in the capital
[Music]
Cala demonstrators bur tires and erected
road block as
well firing live rounds of ammunition
hitting bystanders with stick we're
getting some reports of people being
injured some possibly dead but none of
that has been confirmed
[Music]
yet
I'm writing a letter to my dad cuz the
government put him in prison for no
reason dear Tata I hope you're eating
well in prison we aren't allowed to see
you but at least we can write to you I'm
very scared but you and I should be
strong from me loving the
Shalom the government put my dad in jail
but they're going to go on court this
Thursday on 23rd so and I I I pray that
they clear his name and he set
free but I'm also
scared protesters have marched in
downtown Nairobi Kenya to demand the
release of of an opposition lawmaker in
neighboring
[Applause]
[Music]
Uganda
com wine MP and musicians sat before a
military Court in Gulu and after 10 days
in military custody he looked exhausted
and in
pain the court Marshal prosecutor told
him that the Army had withdrawn the
charges of illegal possession of
firearms you are accordingly set free
unless being held on other
charges Bobby wine was overcome by
emotion but his freedom was not to
be he was immediately handed over to the
police to be charged with treason and
sent to appear before a magistrate at
the civilian Court in
town
you are charged off
ofon
HT
and unw aimed and through stones and
smashing the rare wind scream over the
presidential
car it is the considered opinion of this
that their choosed person are allowed to
access their private doctors at any time
as to ensure that their health is
guaranteed I
so what kind of society we living in
where democratic reelected politicians
beat lock for no good
reason for
[Applause]
[Music]
all
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm president already I'm president of
the
ghetto
happy to see me how are you good to see
you
guys for
me
why are you going to America I'm going
to America because you know what
happened they injected me I don't know
it so I'm going to America so that the
doctor has removed all the bad things
they me yeah I would have stayed with
you guys but I have to go to America so
that my body is
[Music]
clean yes
honey can I put this in your bag no
you'll give it back to
me we are going to the US tentatively
maybe for treatment but there is so much
that's going to happen uh we contacted a
human rights lawyer the US and he has
organized a number of press
conferences
um I don't know for how long we'll be
gone I'm worried about the children cuz
they're staying behind and the
uncertainty that comes around that whole
journey is
just
stressful
the MP and former pop star Bobby wine
who was released on baale in Uganda last
week flew straight to Washington he's
been a staunch critic of President
musani who's led the country for more
than 30 years uganda's government denies
Bobby wine was tortured and insists he
should return to Uganda to face trial
for treason good
morning thank you very much for coming
today
uh we are very grateful and privileged
uh to have with us the honorable Robert
chulani also known as Bobby
wine thank you ladies and
gentlemen um it should be noted that I'm
not presenting myself as a victim
because I'm nobody's victim I'm a
Survivor and I would rather represent
resilience
and yes I'm also here to symbolize the
resilience of ugandans to tell them that
we still stand for justice equality
freedom and dignity for everybody we
represent the power of the people um
ugandans have always been wanting
Freedom they've always been wanting to
be the masters of their Destiny they've
always wanted to live in a country where
leaders are servants and the people are
the true
[Music]
Masters and do you think this is an
isolated incident with you is there a a
wider Uprising happening how much of a
threat are
you it is not just me so many other
ugandans are going through the same the
people that I was arrested with many
were tortured in the the same manner
actually others
worse so I'm only speaking up not only
for myself but for many other ugandans
that are going through the
same are you still scared what is your
plan going forward I'm not scared
because there's nothing to be scared
about uh living in Uganda is like not
living at all um we've been in operation
for the longest time I believe that the
young people of Uganda especially um
have a new
Awakening um a new ownership of their
country Uganda is my country I will
never have any other country that is
where I was born and that's where I will
die we are confident and we believe that
the more we come together is uh we are
going to be able to reclaim our country
to reclaim our freedom and to reclaim
our dignity and we are not going to give
up Bobby wine Robert Amsterdam thank you
very much for joining us here on CNN
thank
[Music]
you yes I can hear you bro no Bobby I
I'm from the airport I just took Bobby
to the airport man Bobby went back
home feeling so empty
now all right bro
okay
cheers I think used to be my favorite
revolutionary and it's very very
disturbing that I'm at war with my once
favorite you know no Ugandan would have
had a better story than
y but I really really would love to have
a Frank and honest conversation with him
I be like Mr President what happened to
you you used to you you say that
Africa's
problem are the leaders that
overstaining power what
happened you promise so many
things
[Music]
yeah
youy
I am
home you go and
sleep yeah you can't sleep and we catch
up tomorrow
morning see you
tomorrow oh
God I'm
home it's like a a
dream I don't know what to feel this
this place is not safe for even the
least expected people so I I have no
guarantee that I'm
safe yeah but at least even I m not
being safe I'm with the children that's
what I was worried about the
most yeah we can handle from here when
I'm with
them
yeah
[Music]
what would stop you from becoming like
the president is now what would stop you
from becoming someone who just kept hold
of power and became the same as the man
that you would replace well that's a
fear why because many of the things I'm
saying today our president said when he
was my age because I also know that
power corrupt and corrupts absolutely so
what's important is to empower our
people
is the only way we can confir that never
again will a president be a king in
Uganda one last question are you hopeful
for uganda's
future I'm very hopeful for uganda's
future I know that regardless of the
operation I know that no matter how many
people are tortured imprisoned or even
killed I know that freedom will come to
Uganda some
someday today we never went to school
because tata's coming
back everyone so excited that s coming
back that they had they have to
celebrate they are putting up
balloons even they have cakes for
Tata because you know people love
Tata but not as much as we love
him call stepen and bring a box of water
and give it to
them
[Applause]
our future president is back in
Uganda that is our future
President we are going to stay in the
house we the children are staying in the
house that is going to come and greet
you talk to you and then go outside and
talk to those people so they can go so
we going to open those Gates and those
people are going to come in we have to
greet people talk to people no we going
to talk to people they will be out
here open
[Applause]
that the last stretch of a long journey
home but Bobby wine didn't receive a
warm welcome upon arrival at Ina
International
Airport a friend of the pop star turned
politician filmed police waited for him
on the
[Music]
tarmac
they're bringing him straight
here he was swept from the airport in
this Convoy a few supporters raced to
keep
up some who tried to cheer him faced the
Wrath of the
army
[Music]
[Applause]
the word was out Bobby wine was being
allowed home a quick look to confirm it
was him in the
car and then the last last
yards inside this vehicle Bobby wine
returning home the very F that he's been
allowed to come here is a big political
victory for him and the moment of Joy
his
[Applause]
supporters
he told them he would end three decades
of one man's
Rule and in a country where 3/4 of the
population is under 35 the promise is
intoxicating
[Music]
a
I'm sorry guys I'm totally exhausted but
I'm finally home and I'm glad to be here
I'm sorry I will be able to address a
press conference much later but I'm glad
to be home will you fight AR are you you
going to fight I have come to continue
exactly where I stopped I am going to
fight on and like I said we must get our
freedom or we shall die trying to get
our
freedom people power our power our power
people
[Music]
power
people power is not a political party
it's a
movement that unites all chain seing
forces we don't care about your tribe we
don't care about your religion anded we
don't care about your political
affiliation we believe that today Uganda
is divided into two parts the oppressors
and the oppressed now we come together
as the oppressed people of Uganda to
demand that power goes back
people I am personally willing and ready
to lead you in this
struggle I want this message to go not
to anybody else but to president
on of the people of Uganda I am
challenging you to a free
[Applause]
[Music]
election no leader has ever handed over
power peacefully to another in the
history of our
country it's a consequence of Gan
V this is a military
regime just very thinly dressed in a
civil kind of
facade but uh it's essentially a
military regime that you cannot vote
out
well the Corona virus surface at the end
of December in China fast forward one
month and is infected thousands of
people around the world that the
Ministry of Health has confirmed the
first Corona virus case in Kenya the
Ministry of Health would like to inform
the general public that Uganda has
confirmed her first case of Corona virus
disease coid
the bad news is that everyone is a
potential victim but the good news is
that everyone is a potential solution
sensitize the masses to sanitize keep a
social distance and
quarantine stop the Corona
virus Everybody Must Be Al a global pmic
we can never
a of life we can take for
[Music]
GR discipline and person and make sure
you regularly wash your hands keep a
distance from everyone rep anything like
a simp serious is a
simp is a
simp
[Music]
I think I'm done
right yeah together we can fight
[Music]
this
the government has been trying to
distribute food to vulnerable
communities in Kampala and wakiso who
are deemed unable to survive the ongoing
coid 19
lockdown we think that President M and
his government are politicizing uh the
coid 19 pandemic to the detriment of
ugandans from blocking ugandans from
extending relief to their neighbors and
again the overall corruption as we see
we've seen women going to police
stations with their children and
demanding to be arrested so they can
feed off that food that means the food
is not reaching where it's supposed to
reach president M has banned the
unauthorized distribution of food after
opposition MP Francis Zak was seen
delivering food to his
constituents security operatives raided
M municipality MP Francis Zak's home and
arrested
him the MP is accused of Distributing
food to his constituents contrary to the
president's
directives about giving out food I'll
give it
out this is people just arresting those
who are
get now this this idiot is you come I
give you food you are an enemy they're
going to crush
you
that's
play was very
painful some d
fore
speee
spee
[Music]
it would not be wise for directions for
me if you ask me and many many ugandans
because of what we see that the
scientific elections will not be viable
they are not viable the scientific
elections are for the benefit and
advantage of the incumbents
[Music]
only
I give you a go ahead to fly your
[Applause]
umbrellas
what was the cause ofar just no no we
are not going to delay
here
they have taken
documents we were preparing to take his
signatures that we have collected from
different parts of the country uh to the
Electoral Commission on Friday and uh
many of those documents are now
missing their plan is try and frustrate
honorable ch's being on the ballot paper
that's their
plan man man man these guys are turning
us into criminals in our own
country they have literally deployed
everywhere
we're living
dangerously salutation yeah when they
broke into my office they took all the
signatures that we had collected for
nomination yes for my
nomination they even took some money I'm
told they've taken to the tune of 23
million which we had fundraised to help
our candidates nominate so where does it
leave your aspirations to be president
well we are not giving up we have
immediately communicated to our branches
to ensure that they start collecting the
signatures immediately and hopefully by
Friday we shall go to have the required
signatures we had been able to collect
over 7 million signatures and these guys
took them
away so we're trying trying to now get
all of them back um because you you
should have 100 per district and I think
so far we lack about how many district
18 18 about 18 districts which are not
yet here yeah because if the if the
commission is assists on the deadline of
tomorrow then it means that we really
really have to work extra extra hard to
get these
signatures in place
today
[Music]
today is the first step to the freedom
of our nation and we hope to achieve it
in the name of the almighty
God
I think they're trying to delay
me or to block me from
reaching the nomination Center and time
we should be in chambo in about an hour
if we to follow the appointment that The
Honorable CH has with the election
commission
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
The
Honorable does not have a lot of time on
his
handsies successfully nominated must
have been supported by 100 registered
voters from 98 districts we will also
look for proof of payment of the
nonrefundable fee of 20
million and we find that he has
satisfied the
requirements therefore I declare that s
Robert de nominated
candidate
[Music]
to all the people of
Uganda wherever you are I am coming to
[Music]
you
ug where
[Applause]
are got any major problems in Pat we had
issues with accommodation um all all
hotels in town being ordered not to host
us but beyond that we've not had any
major challenges with security and we
hope that that can continue across um
The Campaign
[Music]
schedule we are the future we are the
CH we are the youngest population in
the we are the leaders of the future and
the future is to be if we only come
together we can
[Applause]
[Music]
change
you it's just like a miracle man when
you go everywhere you find people power
I don't even know how it gets
there even in the most remote places
you'll find our support
[Music]
there it is overwhelming because before
they used to say that we are only in the
Central and not any other part of Uganda
but they've been this Pro this
overwhelming
[Music]
[Applause]
you
it
[Music]
okay my boss my
boss I am not a criminal I am a presid c
I do not
anything
after his arrest chani was whisked away
to Nala police station in Jer
District the presidential candidate for
the national Unity platform Robert Chi
is in there and we are awaiting what
happens
[Applause]
[Music]
next
it
[Music]
in other the news at least 16 people
have been killed in Uganda in a
Crackdown on protesters calling for the
release of presidential candidate Bobby
Wayne
supporters of the opposition politician
continue to call for him to be released
other presidential candidates have
suspended their campaigns calling for
their fellow contestant to be released
Alliance for National transformation
suspended the campaigns with a view that
all of us should be given equal
treatment and equal status members of
the NM are congregating in high numbers
and the issue of Co doesn't arise I
don't know whether president M decided
that Co attacks only those who are
opposing
him the incumbent has continued to
campaign and
[Applause]
interrupted these people are in they are
non social distancing most of them are
not putting on masks and they are
basically moving in total disregard of
the coid 19 Health
guideline
mom me I'm very scared scar what Mommy
you can't be doing
[Music]
mmy what else to do is look at that guy
trying to point a gun at me like in a
way to say why are you recording
us look at
him right here in the office it's it's a
bullet that just went past my ear
the minister of security General ell
tmin said government will investigate
the shooting
incidents the minister also said there
are certain circumstances under which
security agents can justifiably use life
ammunition against
riers for police there are procedures of
how you change and heighten the
levels police has a right to shoot you
and kill you if you reach a certain
level of
violence according to police figures 28
people were sh dead in various parts of
great
campala so you don't know what okay so
are you are you hoping that he'll get
bailed today yeah or at least be
released we we hope that they consider
to give him bail cuz you know it is his
right and the and and I'm hoping that
the case they bring up against him is
not is uh is something bailable but we
hope we hope at the end of the day he
will be out this obviously very this is
obviously very concerning Barbie
yeah yesterday the police came brutally
to people tear gust them them and shot
at them with life bullets good morning
we have a number of people who died
yesterday and they all died in the
middle of the city center we have masks
you're very keen to talk about the
innocent supporters who've lost their
life but you must be very concerned
about your husband as well we have gone
past that stage of having to ask him to
throw in the towel cuz if not him then
who
else
Freedom National Unity platform
presidential candidate Robert Chan also
CH the East legislator was this
afternoon granted bail by the chief
Magistrate Court in igang the release
brings to an end two tense days that saw
death uniformed and non-uniformed men
shooting dozens of civilians as scores
protested ch's arrest it does bring the
total number of deaths to 49 and still
counting
[Music]
take care man
more than 50 ugandans lost their lives
they were shot by the security
forces tell me about that who's
accountable for that
the the opposition the victims are
responsible for the not the victims the
opposition are the ones who wanted to
organize an
Insurrection because they say they want
to organized here what happened in
Libya supported by you
people what happened in
Egypt what happened in Sudan but was
that really what was happening or was it
that's what they were
planning that's what they were planning
encouraged by by actually Western
Government Western elements I wouldn't
say Western elements press some this and
that some
[Music]
diplomats the 50 ugandans more than 50
lost their lives and it was the
security 32 we attacking security people
there was a 14-year-old boy who was
killed who was walking along behind his
mother some some died in the crossfire
some died some 22 but 32 we definitely
who started that
violence well who started wine was
arrested and then people started rioting
of that there is no doubt
yes so who are who are we sponsible the
ones who put those bankrupt ideas in the
heads of some of the obviously not so
capable
actors and they they get quite a lot of
encouragement from
from the foreigners from the homosexuals
from I don't know what what have the
homosexuals got to do with it oh they
are very happy they are very happy with
Bobby
W Bobby W in particular is an agent of
foreign interest and that was a a
rehearsal that one CU that's what they
wanted
but it was
defeated so as we were driving to C the
police and military Unleashed Terror
they shot uh taras and live
ammunition uh one lady was shot her leg
was
smashed another young man was shot twice
in the legs and an elderly man was shot
in the ribs that is how it was in
C I want to say very importantly that we
are nonviolent and we continue to preach
nonviolence even if president M he has
been trying to project us as a violent
group of young people so that he can get
justification to hand this violence to
[Applause]
us
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
strong magician
strong
I'm
[Music]
sorry
just a few minutes away from our
campaign venue the police started
shooting bullets and deers at us when I
came out to ask them why they are doing
this they opened fire and as you could
see the head of my security afato has
been shot in the eye producer Dan magic
who moves right closely with me in the
same car has been shot his mouth and
face has been shattered and his teeth
have been removed these people it is
evident that they are targeting our life
lives they're targeting my life we are
not going to stop we are not going to
give
up it is our right it is within the law
that we meet the people of Uganda and we
talk to them we are not committing a
crime
so what's
happening who is in charge of
this who's the leader of these
[Music]
officers
don't you think if we call an airline
they could help
us is there a way we can book those
tickets on that price and then clear
cash tomorrow we are having an election
just 8 days from now and you've all seen
how dangerous it has
been I was always telling in this
to be careful because now 7 is targeting
everybody around me you know what
happened to everybody including aonian
yes they are still in prison
now so we are in very dangerous
times and
therefore I am forced to remove my
family from
here
okay uh mama and I agreed that uh to
make sure that that our children are
safe okay we're going to send
you um to be with Aunt
Bridget in
America mama and me will
stay because the nation needs
us we shall be
safe okay when the situation settles
down here you'll come back home and
start
school okay
I'll be talking to you people every day
so don't
worry
yeah yes subie has her books here we can
go with them make sure subie learns how
to read and write just do that I know
how to read those books get thoughts
good be confident
children be
prayerful think about us every day we
will be think about
you you know and we hope you will never
ever have to run away from your country
ever again after
this
the first truckload of nup prisoners
arrived at masaka this
afternoon among them were his music
collaborators Dan magic and ubian Lee as
well as his bodyguard Eddie
mat the group was paraded in front of
masaka Chief magistrate Chelsea who read
out charges on engaging in an act likely
to spread an infectious disease and
inciting of
violence the suspects pleaded not guilty
to all
charges
great yeah hope everyone can hear me
okay thanks so much uh for joining us
appearing today for the next 60 Minutes
will be Bobby himself there a question
for Bobby I just just wanted to ask
uh as a matter of fact as a matter of
fact I would really really now
I'm you
can oh my
God I'm not allowed to speak to the
media this is a senior police officer
you are embarrassing our country okay
I'm sorry that this is
happening I'm sorry they they are
shooting but um I hope you can still
hear me we can hear
you from the look of things um I am
looked at as a criminal as a rebel and
I'm treated as such
and uh my most important mission is to
be
alive in 7even days from
[Music]
now
the American ambassador to Uganda
Natalie Brown announced today that the
US has canel its observation of
tomorrow's election in a statement today
she claimed that 75% of the US Observer
accreditations have been denied by
uganda's electoral commission the
European Union announced that they won't
be sending observers to monitor the
election the government's failure to
implement previous election
recommendations appears to be the main
[Music]
issue
we are alive we have managed to make it
to the
last some have
died some are in
prison others are in
hiding have been left alone is
related with most of our
friends in either of the places but yeah
election day is here and we will go with
the rest of
ugandans and the both out
of
[Music]
don't
need it looks like an orderly process
but the Ugandan government is obviously
very anxious about this election
otherwise why cut the internet and all
local mobile data and international data
all you can do on your phone now is make
an old-fashioned
call the economy is dependent on the
internet what the government wants is to
make sure that ugandans cannot
communicate about this election with
each other or to the outside
world the results that we will get will
most likely not see you as a winner and
will be the result of of the regime what
do you expect from from the European
Union and others to to as an
reaction I will not say what I expect
I'll say what I request the United
States gives Way Beyond $100
million you know to Uganda the European
Union supports Uganda a great deal
question is do they know what they are
supporting the people of Uganda while
they appreciate the
assistance would want the European Union
and America and all development Partners
to make respect for Democratic
principles and human rights a
precondition for all that
Aid because we share values values of
humanity values of Human Rights values
of
democracy we also want to be like them
we want to develop but the first imped
of development is
dictatorship and it is clearly being
sponsor sponsored by our development
Partners this father shows them that
they are
indeed propping up a monster in
Uganda once upon a time they blocked Aid
coming to Uganda because the rights of
the gay people were being
abused now note that the rights of gay
people are being respected but rights of
our our whole population are being
abused so we request them to be as
assertive as they were
[Music]
then
stay safe ensure that you are at
large our home is surrounded by
soldiers we just come in too my house
and without anybody instructing it do
you know you are trespassing in my house
you know this is our
compound if you are visitors you should
introduce
yourselves Madame did you come to visit
me you know the dusty road that leads to
Bobby wi's house is starting to resemble
a a military installation now there are
a lot of troops there are special forces
there are riot police and we've seen
several prison Vans Go
in all right so what has happened none
of us is allowed to access him
effectively he is under house
arrest
look these things are being done by the
regime because they guilty know the
guilty run before their chest because
yes if you think you organized a free
and fair election why are you be
scar
this of course there's nothing to panic
about
yeah
ugandans are in the dark again tonight
the internet is still blocked Mr wine is
under extreme pressure most of his AIDS
have been arrested some have been killed
and he's at home alone with his wife
Barbie
now
we have a completely different report
and uh all the people that were able to
observe the elections have a completely
different report General is fabricating
those results and that is why uh he has
completely shut down the internet
switched off all the phone numbers of my
my wife and all the leadership
many in many cases people were not even
allowed to vote but even in areas where
people were allowed to vote it is
evident that uh the results are
projecting more votes than the
registered voters this is the most
fraudulent election in the history of
Uganda thank you very
much the greatest challenge of our
generation is removing the
dictator said he has been reelected for
another time in office after scoring
58.64 in the just concluded election his
rival Robert P
[Music]
34%
one of Africa's longest serving leaders
president mevani has claimed 58% of the
vote arguably this election was less a
democratic exercise and more a ritual to
consolidate the power structure that's
been in Uganda for three and a half
decades
we'll never be safe here until my is
gone
but can never
so I think our children are unsafe
coming back
here
T the children can't stay there if the
children got to stay one of us would
have to stay with
them that means you would have to stay
here what does one
do
what
[Music]
momy
hey buppy hey
[Music]
buppy
speech
[Music]
for
[Applause]
[Music]
get
how
Fighting For
[Music]
Freedom we are fighting for
freedom I say we are fighting for
freedom
[Music]
we are fighting for
Freedom we go
forward because we know that freedom is
ahead so we go forward we move forward
yeah send it to them
brother
[Music]
so when the going get
STP stop get going especially when
leaders become
misleaders mentors become to mentors
when freedom of expression becomes the
target of
Separation opposition becomes our
[Music]
[Applause]
opposition
[Music]
for
thank you thank you hope you're having a
good time we've always
try to find a way you should also try to
find a way let make life brighter and
better give me some more
Vibes well if you feel like giving up
remember you
started I can see your the tears in your
eyes everything shows you want to give
up and I can feel your pain and your
grief and your fears and all your
frustra but you got to be strong let
your TR no one keep you down you got to
rise up since about tomorrow and look
beyond your fears there are days when
the sky not blue and everything is a
sign of Doom trust in God and believe in
him trust in God and believe in
him one day everything is going to be
fine everything going to be fine one day
everything will be you
right one day everything is going to be
fine everything going to be Fay
everything will be all
right I say you will overcome every
situation it seems impossible until it's
done better days must come and the sun
will rise no matter how dark the night
might be nobody will have a right to
kill another man over we in theast
hospital with good medication every
youth will have a chance to go school
sheding blood the street human rights
violation no more everybody will have
the
opportunity one day everything is going
to be fine everything going to be fine
somay everything will be all
right one day everything is going to be
fine everything going to be fine somay
everything will be all right
[Music]
so remember your pain is not in vain
that is how you get the experience and
what doesn't kill you makes you strong
never give the negativity one day you
will look back and smile and you will
have a story to tell and you and
perseverance they hard they squeeze they
sweet they where there's no pain there
is no gain victory has never come easy
remember in life there ups and downs
never give the negativity no one day
everything is going to be
fine everything going to be fine one day
everything will be all
right one day everything is going to be
fine everything going to
somay everything will be all
[Music]
right